pas de temps à perdre pour un ace à
peine revenu de son voyage à milan elle
n'a qu'une envie reprendre
l'entraînement toujours les championnats
du monde en tête ce sont les jeux
paralympiques qu'elle vise schalit aux
championnats du monde pour essayer de
décrocher un quota
donc il travaillait était fait et puis
les chronos n'ont pas cessé de descendre
au cours des courses donc ça aussi c'est
que le travail était fait
je fais une sixième place et
potentiellement c'est un quota pour les
jeux de son côté rémy est revenu des
championnats de france de gérardmer il y
a quelques semaines lui aussi avec des
résultats satisfaisants et des envies de
rio mais entre cinq et six secondes des
meilleurs mondiaux donc
ce qui est pas mal parce que a fortiori
normalement l'année prochaine j'aimerais
avoir un bateau encore un peu plus
rapide et puis bah avec un entraînement
je pense que ces cinq secondes fait je
vais manger assez rapidement je pense
d'eux a ni de champion et deux histoires
agnès à 40 ans le kayak elle a connu il
ya quelques années avant son accident de
voiture
mais c'est après que le loisir est
devenu une passion pour cette jeune
femme mordus de sport il ya deux ans le
kayak est devenu paralympiques
donc on m'a dit bête toi café du sport
au niveau toi qu'a fait du kayak ça te
dirait pas d'aller à rio rio je sais pas
la rio
mais monter en kayak oui ok le sport
c'est ce qui a aussi motivé rennie le
jeune militaire de 27 ans perd l'usagé
de ses jambes lors d'un saut en
parachute
mais à sa sortie de l'hôpital il n'avait
qu'une idée en tête faire du kayak
on va dire que les gens
entre guillemets ne voyais pas le
handicap retrouver son kayak et puis on
a quand même une autonomie exactement
comme les valides qu au final par les
sanglots consorts bis ou pas même si les
performances sans forcément à moindre
mais de retour sur terre les difficultés
et reviennent sans pour autant faire
dériver les deux champions de leur but
2016 rio et les premiers jeux
paralympiques de kayak